[Music]
based on quantum physics
particles are continuously created their
only destiny is to meet and disappear
into each other the same thing happens
when two people fall in love
i really needed you last night i was
busy training i'm always busy and i
still find time for you
how'd it go today
we're not there yet someone yeah i know
keep this up you're not gonna make the
team you only be living in that trailer
camp rest of your life do you roy
do you know where steve is i don't know
where he went come on have some fun
[Music]
do you believe in love yes i do i just
don't want it
do you remember anything about that
night
i
don't remember
it wasn't your fault
she's convinced that she was with steve
that night and steve is telling the same
story
what was i wearing i can't remember them
i'll never forgive myself
what happened between the two of you
that night
turn around
[Music]
the bond between two particles
is only valid in the microscopic realm
you weren't with me why are you lying
it cannot be applied to the human world
because human beings
are much more complicated
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you